welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Kang the Conqueror is out of
gas in the quantum realm according to
Marvel head Kevin feige ahead of the
Kickstart to Marvel phase five with
Ant-Man and the Watts Quantum Mania the
latest trailers have shown us Kang's
vessel which in this movie he will
attempt to get online like me trying to
drive a rental car in a foreign country
and realizing it's a stick shift our man
is struggling and unhappy in addition to
trailer footage we now have gotten two
interesting images of Kang with his ship
one earlier this week with Kang sitting
in the Pod with a man spread that says
Brent Slayer won't talk to me anymore
anyway so I'm not gonna make room for
any woman and then in recent days an
even more interesting shot of Kang with
that device that I think fuels The
Vessel perhaps the kind of quantum
generator with a glowing tube flowing
into it the same device that we actually
saw Kang handling in the first trailer
check this out Kang is wearing different
simpler clothes and in any other shot
we've seen him in looks like a tunic
with a thick Obi-Wan Kenobi belt so this
may be an earlier time in the quantum
realm when Janet Van Dyne knew him so
what exactly is Kang's ship how does it
work and what kind of fuel does it
require well I have an explanation and
that connects the dots between the war
that is now raging through the quantum
realm and even why Kang's variant he
remains was so worried about activating
Sylvie to come find him exactly when he
did in Loki episode 1. so Marvel Studios
isn't really making any secrets about
This ship's existence or Kang's interest
in it Kevin feige told Empire Kang's a
very powerful person but when we meet
him he's in a position where he needs to
get that power back he has a ship and a
device that would allow him to go
anywhere in any win if he can get it
online if only he had access to Genie
scientists with Pym particles so a ship
and a device I think that chair pod that
he sits in is his time travel or at
least the cockpit of the ship in fact
the full ship could be a city-sized
battleship and that's what those Rings
get into place are and the device is
this generator that we see him with but
it is fueled by something that glowing
tube beating into the generator could be
an important clue previous videos I
pointed out how the shot of Scott and
hope when they arrive in the quantum
realm this craggy Broken Field with vast
Columns of glowing energy in other shots
of the trailer like when Jenna Van Dyne
walks through a more tropical jungle
setting what looks like the Horizon the
background is actually a glowing golden
pipeline my theory was that those
columns that Scott and hope see are
drills mining this energy from the
quantum realm terrain and then piping it
back somewhere I think Kang's base for
refining into a fuel source that it can
use to reactivate its time ship to
escape the quantum realm and now with
this new trailer and things that we've
learned about quantumania the details
seem to be supporting that Katie O'Brien
is playing Freedom Fighter jentora whom
the official press release describes
like this gentura is the strong and
respected leader of the Freedom Fighters
a group of displaced inhabitants in the
quantum realm whose lives were turned
upside down by Kang she doesn't have
time for Scott Cassie and their problems
and worse their presence alone puts
gentura's crew in grave danger I think
gentore is part of the ragtag group who
approached Scott and Cassie in this
location I think the reason this land is
so broken up is that Kang as he's been
building his army and Mining this land
for fuel has ecologically destroyed This
Land once owned by these residents
turning them into an antagonistic
militia the reason Scott and Cassie are
such game changers is they have access
to pimp article technology that would
make Kang's objective even easier to
shrink down further into a realm beyond
the quantum realm down into the Nexus
roots of existence with their own
quantumly chaotic physics to shrink and
to snatch the original Wellspring of
this golden energy source so that Kang
can stop digging for it bit by bit and
just keep the whole damn thing
perpetually generating energy inside his
ship's generator now I've been
re-watching Loki season 1 and another
detail just came up that blew my mind
when we first met Sylvie at the end of
that first episode The TVA has been
chasing this Loki variant and she's been
luring them into these anachronistic
Nexus events in order to steal their
reset charges but when they go to 1858
Oklahoma they find the device that
caused the Nexus a futuristic shovel
brought back to 1858 if you look closely
it was created by Advanced idea
mechanics so that's aim and what is it
designed to dig for Quantum or so what
the is quantum ore we all just kind
of overlooked that with all the other
stuff Loki was throwing at us I guess we
considered it a joke about a future that
truly does put the word Quantum in front
of everything but hey you know what time
it is Bam it's geology time geology is
the 16 time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and now they offer products for
whatever you need just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology
figures out your routine for you geology
creates simple and effective skin care
and Hair Care routines customized just
for you with ingredients that are proven
to work no matter what you're trying to
take care of for Hair Care youth
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses hair without the
harsh ingredients in typical shampoo
geology also has body washes that are
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable for skin care geology
can protect your skin from environmental
stress with vitamin C plus e for Relic
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant right now for limited time
geology is hooking our viewers up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code rockstar70 they will give you
an additional 70 off their award-winning
skincare trial set we did the math and
that's five products for just fifteen
dollars on top of that you can take an
additional 30 bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add
that to your trial to get started just
click the link in the description but I
think Quantum ore might be a natural
resource discovered in future years on
Earth that powers advanced technology
whatever the future has to replace
fossil fuels with like we know there's
got to be some major breakthrough in the
future of the MCU when it comes to
energy consumption like remember look
episode 2 established that and he
remains sacred timeline natural and
ecological disasters start escalating on
Earth both in frequency and intensity
Mobius brings up the extinction of the
swallow that really screwed up the
ecosystem category 8 hurricanes are
destroying rocks on company towns if
things get that bad on Earth in just the
next half century how the hell could
Earth Society ever make it to the 31st
Century with technology good enough for
Nathaniel Richards to do some dabbling
into the Multiverse I mean based on the
mcu's current trajectory we're going to
be at Mad Max by year 2100. now there
are a lot of reasons he remains in okay
with the sacred timeline spiraling the
status of Earth into apocalyptic chaos
like the guy obviously has a death wish
but specifically I think he's okay with
companies like Roxanne taking over our
lives the way Amazon currently is in our
world because it's gonna be companies
like Roxanne and aim who are going to
make these breakthroughs with things
like Quantum ore and Mankind will
finally finally be able to stop using
fossil fuels Quantum ore would be a
tangible crystalline minable resource on
the surface realm fed by subatomic
Wellsprings down in the quantum realm so
by trying to steal Quantum ore Sylvie
might have actually been trying to cut
off the TVA which at the time she did
not know was being run by a Kang but to
cut off the TVA from functioning
properly from keeping the lights on the
time doors opening up the reset charge
is working Miss minutes dead because you
won't like her when she gets hungry and
as soon as Sylvie start digging in that
Earth he who remains scripted it so that
Loki a1130 would cause a Nexus event and
could activate a chain reaction of
events that led to the finale of Loki
and removed Sylvie from the path that
she was on so I think this Quantum ore
this Quantum energy is going to be the
lifeblood for Kang as the Avenger try to
stay a step ahead of him in their
upcoming battles like Avengers King
Dynasty since this fuel was probably
cashed in deposits throughout history
and Kang would be the only one who knows
about them that'll give him countless
times and places to go recharge and
respawn as The Avengers try to chase him
throughout the time stream so let me
know your thoughts on this and a
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive launching February 17th
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you